this is the Battle of Britain and for me
to the best restaurants are going
head-to-head for the very first time
there's no undercover footage there's no
coat it's just you on a plate it's 20
stunning dishes and that is it make sure
as you go to the semi-final good luck
I've asked them to create their dishes
using a classic British ingredient
venison these are two amazing westerns
come head-to-head and for me the best of
British always exciting norm any other
category I'm expecting crow flavors
great balance and phenomenal fireworks
I've invited 20 esteemed guests to judge
both teams creations the diners include
Elizabeth Carter editor of The Good Food
Guide an award-winning British farmer
Wilfred Emanuel Jones and the front of
house teams from both questions are here
- so in terms of nervousness kellsat my
chance to prove ourselves to West House
for venison loin
grams divides the dish worthy of his
mission start status he's using venison
loin
so with onion marmalade potatoes pickled
cherries and finished with crispy bacon
and venison liver because it's got great
flavor you know but it must be some rare
it's a technical dish with the potential
for disaster especially if grams
control-freak REE prevents sous-chef Ben
from supporting him you will let anyone
do anything what are you actually doing
today apart from making graham tea are
you actually participating in the
cooking honey well no cherries I know
you love taking your time when you put
these dishes together exactly one hour
for 20 not one hour per dish yeah just
in case cuz nobody like when you get
buried away there's no pulling your bag
out there is that my face the grain is
that the food is so complex there's poor
slave elements he just needs to offload
and open up and bring been with him to
get that dish absolutely perfect so for
more venison loin away.now ground please
West nails on table two please Ben send
one table clean your [ __ ] down send the
next table clear [ __ ] down yeah
grams delegating at last but with time
on his hands he started cooking the
delicate venison liver too early that
liver is your danger zone you know that
groan I do
danger zone how do you want to serve it
I want to show it real red so you cook
it rare here it goes out there pink well
it's it's there it's firmus [ __ ]
understand so when he's two thirds of
the plate dress you happy have the
converse you supply that at the last
moment till we win I'm gonna liver yeah
yep you ready yeah go for it - limousine
yeah yeah
and crunch down those cherry stems up a
place they look fantastic absolutely
fantastic no two ways about it
go please cable to do more venison we're
away now please Graham wish yes
Table four please thank you working with
the team at the moment and then he
scrapes things get involved with stuff
on the first allowing me to skip the
liver of things last minute Graham's
happy with these food but will the
diners agree
it smells lovely flavors are all there I
mean exactly what we always get in the
restaurant I'm very proud of him it's a
good dish nearly Graham's dish has set
the bar seriously high - being with a
chance of winning the milestone lad
really have a battle on their hands